hi everyone sal here welcome to our uh
homeroom live stream have an exciting
show we're going to have kristen d'serbo
khan academy's chief learning officer
answering any questions you have about
motivation and having more independence
as a learner but before we get started i
will make my standard announcements uh
first a reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself if you're in a
position to do so so please think about
going to khan academy.org
donate and making a donation i also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that have supported khan
academy through the years but especially
as we went into covid uh our costs went
up as we're trying to accelerate a whole
series of programs our server costs have
gone up so special thanks to bank for
america google.org att fastly novartis
and to the many other organizations that
have
supported khan academy through the years
it's made a huge difference although we
still need more help so please think
about making a donation i'd also like to
announce and i've done this on previous
live streams uh that we are uh we have a
homeroom with sal the podcast as you can
see in that graphic right over there
which are kind of some of the more
notable moments in this homeroom live
stream so encourage you to go uh
wherever you find your podcast subscribe
to it uh hopefully you get a kick out of
it so with that i'm excited to introduce
kristen to serbia who we've had on
before kristen good to see you
hey sal good to be here so for those of
y'all who don't know kristen is khan
academy's chief learning officer which
means that she keeps us
well informed and deep on everything
regarding learning science and academics
and the best way that folks can learn
and help others learn
so kristin
what i want to understand is what tips
do you have you know the question i get
a lot is how do we keep people motivated
right now how do we keep people engaged
how do we you know kids are a lot more
of independence is expected of them so
what tips do you have for
students and parents and teachers trying
to navigate this
yes that is the question all of us here
at khan academy are getting a lot of so
it's clearly something that people are
struggling with quite a bit
as you said i like to look to the
research and see what it says and when
you look across things we can actually
think pretty simply about
what keeps people motivated two things
first we're motivated to do things when
we think we're going to feel successful
at them which kind of makes sense like
who wants to do something if you think
you're going to fail at it that doesn't
seem very fun and then second if we
value the activity if it's something
that's important to us so really we can
boil down a lot of the the tips and
ideas and things to things that are
either going to help us feel successful
or increase the the our perception of
the value of the activity we're doing
and sometimes both of those things
so that's kind of the the simple way of
the land and so to your question about a
couple of tips
one really powerful thing we can do
is to set goals because goal setting and
then monitoring ourselves hits on both
of those
two things about success and value and
so if i
set a goal or if you're a parent or a
teacher and you work with the kid to set
the goal so not just
impose it on them but let them help you
think about what should your goal be
that gives you some buy-in it increases
the value because you're thinking yeah
i'm gonna this is something i care about
i'm going to set the goal to be
something that's important to me
and then as you kind of watch yourself
make progress toward that goal and
actually reach it it turns out you're
experiencing success and there's nothing
that convinces you you might be
successful in the future like actually
having some success
so these can be little goals you know it
can be i'm gonna write five sentences
and then hey i wrote six that's great
uh you know it can be i'm gonna do this
many math problems start out small don't
be like i'm gonna learn all of algebra
in this next two months that's too long
it's too much you're gonna
you know not be able to sustain that so
keep it small but be able to think about
you know what some of those
achievable things that you can do are
i like that so the two big takeaways you
should have a reasonable chance of or or
belief that you can be successful or
feeling a successful and it should be
fun but let me ask a question you know
sometimes like i i'm a a hobbyist
guitarist for example and it's very
tempting for me to uh in the spirit of
wanting to feel successful kind of play
the songs that i already know because i
know i'll succeed at them and
it's fun because i i
i i can kind of get into them more is
that what you're saying like should i
not challenge myself should i not try
the songs that i'm still fumbling
through these bizarre chords and
whatever else
that's definitely not what we want to
say
in fact we want to think about how
we can keep moving forward and one of
the ways that we can frame that is
actually to think about this idea of
growth mindset which has gotten a lot of
play lately and sometimes it feels like
oh growth mindset is just saying hey
work hard and you can do it but when it
comes to learning
what we know is that when you're
learning new things you're actually
changing how your brain works
and we actually have a course
i go to the the courses section down
there in the life skills
and it actually walks students through
some of these ideas about how our brain
actually changes the neurons little
cells in our brains when we're learning
new things make new connections
and
we can we explain that in some videos
and students can can walk through it a
little bit but this idea that your brain
is actually like a muscle it's like when
you're working out and if you you know
keep lifting heavier weights your
muscles get bigger in the same way that
if you keep learning new things your
your brain actually gets denser and it
turns out dense brains are a good thing
um and you can you can learn new things
and build them so if you keep playing
your same songs over and over again
you're not building any of the this new
muscle and this new connections in your
brain but if you're trying new things
you're going to keep improving and next
time you'll be able to play even more
complicated songs and maybe some other
songs that you're interested in learning
so if i were to kind of
figure out the sweet spot there you
definitely shouldn't work on the stuff
that is you know you're definitely going
to succeed on because that's not going
to stretch you and grow those neural
connections and maybe don't work on the
thing that is you know
for me the eddie van halen level uh
because
super hard guitar part yeah
yeah
i i avoid that uh but try the stuff that
i'm i that's stretching me a little bit
and you know another thing i took away
from you is when someone calls me dense
which is has which has happened i take
that as a compliment from now on usually
i'm sure they're
referring to my neural density when they
say that i'm dense
so we have questions
i encourage everyone to ask questions
any questions really about learning
about learning science but education
khan academy for christian and myself if
relevant we have a few questions that
are all uh coming in from facebook cindy
victor kumpen asks my boy went to school
for four years and they took and it took
away all of his motivation it was boring
every day how can i help him getting
enthusiastic again getting back on track
your your advice kristen
well first i'm sorry to hear that that
he's not still excited about learning
and where those things are so there's a
couple things that i would say so one is
you know him better than anyone else and
you can help him make the connections
between what he's learning and the
things he's interested in so when we
talked about that value
one way that we value things we're doing
is because they seem relevant to us
so if you know the things that he's
learning help him make those connections
between
why am i learning this and what it can
do to relate to other things i'm
interested in questions he's asked about
the world and how they how it works
things he wants to be when he grows up
any of those kinds of things the way a
way to help him see some of the meaning
in the the things that he's being asked
to do so that's one way that you can you
know start
bringing some of that that piece back
and the other thing is i would say at
home really encourage those questions
and think about you know when
how he's thinking about how the world
works and wondering about this or you
know the other thing and
why why was the when i peddled my bike
why does that make the wheel move and
start even modeling asking those kinds
of questions and those are the things
that then help you relate back to the
things that the students are learning
and i'll just add to that uh you know i
think there's there's two reasons why
i've seen either myself or other folks
disengage or feel something's boring
oftentimes you feel that it's boring
because you're ready to move ahead but
but you you're getting impatient or
sometimes you feel it's boring that it's
a little overwhelming it's a little it's
all going over your head so to speak and
so one option and you know the i know a
good website for this or a good series
of apps uh especially in math and
science but we have some resources and
other things
but if if you're if your son i believe
it was uh you know goes on khan academy
is able to put even 20 30 minutes a day
start at their level you know it sounds
like your son's been going to school for
about four years so maybe they're in
fourth or fifth grade you know start
them even at the kindergarten level or
start them on the get ready for fourth
grade or get ready for fifth grade
course on khan academy that will allow
them to fill in all their gaps probably
build a little bit of confidence it'll
be a little bit of playing those guitar
songs that he already knows but he might
he might realize that a few of his
chords need a little bit more practice
and he appreciates and then when he gets
to the grade level course he can learn
that in his own time and pace and then
he'll probably not only get caught up
with this class if he wasn't already
caught up but probably get ahead of his
class and you know what i found and i'm
even speaking from personal experience
once you see academic success in one
area you naturally start to get more
curious more engaged your perception of
yourself starts to say i'm a learner i'm
i'm capable of learning and i don't have
to wait for other people to tell me what
to learn i can do this on my own and
then that can bleed over into other
things that can lead into being curious
about science or humanities or politics
or whatever else and you know a lot of
what kristen just mentioned of you know
the real world how does it all fit
together uh i think you know you have a
a better uh shot of of that uh so let's
see other questions here
so from this from greenwich connecticut
kimberly's asking how do i know if my
child is learning if he isn't tested and
if and kimberly has children in grades
three six and nine an eight eighth grade
so how do you know if they're learning
if they are not tested good question
christian your view
that is a good question so first talk to
your child's teachers about what are the
skills that they're supposed to be
learning so not what score they get on
the test but what are the things that
they should know how to do what are the
ideas that they should start to help
start to be understanding
and then there's a couple things you can
do so first is in that conversation with
the teacher get their thoughts about
okay
where do you think my child is in in
getting to do those things but you can
also just start observing the things and
when you're at home and think about um
you know asking them questions
having those conversations with them
that give you some evidence about hey
how well did i think they understand
where this is and what this what this
looks like
the other thing that i would say is i've
done a lot of um
kind of thinking and writing about the
idea of assessment without tests and the
idea is that
particularly now that we're in this
digital world
we can get quite a bit of information as
students are doing learning activities
again another shameless plug for uh the
khan academy website
that helps students be able to
see whether you know what kind of level
they're at or have they have they
mastered this skill or not without
actually taking a test they're getting
it kind of through their practice
activities they are leveling up from
kind of being familiar to the task to
proficient with the task and so by
gathering that data from digital
activities we actually
can eliminate some of the need for the
testing that's kind of a big you know
pressure on on teachers time and on
students time and leads to anxiety and
all of those kinds of things and instead
we can get information from them as
they're as they're learning to be able
to understand
yeah i'll just underline that last
point of you know practice on khan
academy isn't just practice it's
inherently
a little micro assessment every time a
student engages and so that is also a
good way to read and you know we've seen
correlations very strong correlations
between work on khan academy and other
types of benchmark assessments so that's
yeah completely agree so from facebook
there's a question jamie dawson osborne
is asking what about when students don't
understand and the teacher's hands are
tied with how they can teach the lesson
so how does either the student the
parent or the teacher deal with that
kristin
so i'm not sure what hands are tied
implied
my interpretation of that is
my interpretation is the teacher has to
cover let's say negative exponents and
say a seventh grade math class but the
student still doesn't understand basic
exponents but the teacher feels but i
have to cover this negative exponent
standard because
that's what my pacing guy that i got
from the district tells me to do what
should the various parties do in that
scenario and you can imagine that's very
disengaging for students
absolutely um and i think what what we
often see is this tension
that uh you've talked about a lot
between having to keep marching forward
according to what is in the
scope and sequence we call it that list
of what needs to be taught when in the
school year
versus making sure students have time to
master what they're doing and we really
need the balance of both of those things
because on one hand it is important that
students
have exposure to all of that grade level
work and on the other hand it's also
important that they have the opportunity
to fill in gaps of things that maybe
they didn't quite master before or they
have the time to to do this and so one
of the things that we encourage is this
idea of
thinking about potentially spending you
know four days of the classroom per week
on that grade level material and then
one day on what we call personalized
practice the idea that you can
start working with students at the level
where they're they are thinking about
uh filling in some of those gaps
understanding
where they are what what maybe didn't
they quite get to mastery on and giving
them additional practice and instruction
in those areas so that they can within
when they do
again get back to that grade level
material they're ready for it and able
to do it
so i think that's one thing the other
thing that uh that came to mind with the
the hands are tied piece is that
sometimes
the teachers explaining it and
explaining it in the way that they think
about it but just hearing someone else
explain it can give you oh aha that now
i get it um and so that's another way
that some of our videos i think can be
helpful is that they provide a little
bit different way to explain it or to
think about it that someone hasn't maybe
heard before
very very helpful yeah i completely
agree i think in that case whatever we
can do to help that student fill in
their gaps so that they can engage it's
going to be optimal so a couple of
related questions uh riffith tanvir from
facebook is asking do you think
motivation is an illusion uh they've
been watching motivational videos but
they feel like it hasn't been helpful
for them a similar question from youtube
miss
victoria
the eyes are all numbers
how can you become more self-motivated
so yeah you know you hear this thing
like motivation yes so-and-so is
motivated so-and-so is not motivated
what is that is that like some do we
have like a motivation gene is it
contextual
uh can you improve it
so
absolutely it is uh not something that's
pre-programmed in you and you either are
not
very it's very much uh contextual you
can be motivated to do one thing and not
motivated to do something else and
that's very common um i hear lots of
parents say gosh my kid seems really
motivated to uh play my
minecraft but not motivated at all to
read books um so it's it's definitely
something that you know you can think
about changing
to the point of is it you know
the thing that's not going to change it
is like motivational slogans so you know
just hey keep working hey you're doing
great like people don't really believe
that if it's not their experience
and so
there's definitely we want to think
about that this idea of authentic
success and giving these messages about
why we think that they can do this and
why we think they'll be successful which
goes back to some of the things we were
talking about earlier about
you know if you understand how this is
actually you know changing your brain
and how working hard can actually lead
to those kinds of changes and
improvements that then can help
think about okay now i understand why i
might be motivated as opposed to just
keep working hard um
so doing that getting some of that kind
of authentic
success going in is important and then
as as we think about how to
one of the things that uh research talks
about a lot is a difference between what
they call external motivation and
intrinsic motivation and so external
motivation is being motivated by things
from the outside so like getting rewards
for what you're doing and intrinsic is
being motivated from internal things
because it makes you happy it brings you
joy
you find it interesting and so one of
the questions is how to move kids from
not wanting to do something to maybe
being internally motivated to do it and
so i get also a lot of questions about
you know is is giving my kids rewards
just bribing them that seems wrong
but it's okay to use rewards sometimes
to bridge the gap between i don't want
to do this and to get into
a little taste of it that getting a
little success that will lead them to
success so it's not bad to think about
small rewards i'm talking about you know
maybe it's playing a board game maybe
it's picking what's for dinner you know
those kinds of things as rewards that
something that's meaningful for your
student your kid
that gives them a little reason to try
something and then get an experience of
it that they can then build on so that's
one of the ways we can think about kind
of moving towards being more
intrinsically motivated
i like that and it resonates with me and
it makes me feel less guilty last night
for bribing my kids with uh being able
to watch shira so that they can take a
bath uh but i'd like to believe that
that extrinsic motivation over time they
will recognize the intrinsic benefits of
being clean
and not stinking
you've also got society helping you with
that a little bit once they start yeah
right that might be extrinsic motivation
too when when you're stinky people might
give you some external feedback uh that
that makes you realize that you you need
to take a bath um more more questions uh
here so how do you this is from facebook
andrea uk lara says how do you motivate
preschoolers in a virtual classroom
there's
one of the things to think about with
kids who are really that age is not even
motivation but just attention spans
and
making sure first that you have
realistic expectations of what a
preschooler can do in a zoom class we're
talking fairly you know short time
frames if you know a few minutes on any
particular activity if you look to
things like
sesame street in terms of you know how
often they're switching to a new thing
that they're doing
we can't expect we shouldn't expect
preschoolers to be able to sit for a
30-minute zoom class doing all of the
same you know kind of activity so one
you're going to want to talk to your
child's teacher make sure that they're
you know doing intro
you know making those switches to doing
different things thinking about how
you're structuring that time that
they're expected to be in so that's the
first thing i would say
and so then the second piece is just
thinking about what is it that is in
those activities that is related to
things that they're excited about things
that they're interested in make those
connections hey did you ever wonder why
you know the
why our our dog and our cats are you
know
one goes out for a walk every day and
the cat doesn't i don't know you know
just like it's silly questions that
you might be able to think about
and think about how what they're doing
in classroom in the classroom can can
bring those kinds of ideas in but with
younger kids again
manage your expectations about what
they're going to be able to do in this
environment
yeah i know it makes a lot of sense and
i would just add to that you know i have
my youngest is almost six uh five and a
half years old and what i've seen his
teachers do really well is just do
quirky funny things all the time
intersperse whatever they're trying to
do with just some goofiness some moving
around and to your point kristen like
not do you know long stretches and four
or five or six year old a long stretch
could even be 15 minutes or 20 minutes
but try to break it up and try to make
it as interactive as possible i also do
want to make sure folks tune in for
tomorrow's are going to be 100th show
and the person who can help answer some
of these questions about motivating
kindergarteners and preschoolers uh
tabitha ross broy she's the 2020
national teacher of the year uh so
hopefully she can give us some tips as
well on motivating uh that that crowd
which i'm sure i can benefit from here
at home
so you know from youtube
just to echo that that teachers
have
great experience doing this and lots of
good tips so just echo encouraging
people to tune in for that
yeah my my other
last tip and i would even call this a
pro tip because i'm not a pro by any
stretch of the imagination is stick with
it with the young kids even they are
very capable of eventually forming some
of these habits uh and and and once they
see some wins uh they too can get a
little bit more motivated well i've seen
that with my own uh with my own son
who's five since you know uh distance
learning started so from youtube kaushik
jaw says
i started feeling depressed and thinking
about goals covet literally makes me go
through anxiety so what what advice do
you have for that christian i i don't
think kashuk is alone i think there's a
lot of folks that you know you have
kovid you have the economy you have
other stuff going on in the world that
is causing a lot of stress and then on
top of that people are trying to figure
out you know their own life and you know
i don't know if kaushik is a student or
is working or whatever but what are your
goals am i achieving what i need to is
it easier or harder now i'm less
connected with friends how do you
recommend people navigate this and maybe
you know try to try to get out of that
and try to maybe hopefully make some uh
uh forward progress on on some of their
goals
absolutely so i'm going to take this
from first starting just from the the
learning perspective which and just say
keep it simple
we don't have to do everything while
we're in this code situation
we'll be out of it at some point we'll
get a vaccine we'll be able to go out in
the world
if we can just make sure we're keeping
up the foundations right now that's the
important thing so for younger kids just
make sure they're doing some math
they're they're doing some reading
they're getting some just you know
keeping up their curiosity about the
world
those are really the important things
that you're doing for students that are
a little bit older again think about
what are the most important things for
them to be learning this year what are
the the biggest pieces that you know we
want to make sure they get and
let's let let yourself go
with all of the the things that come in
terms of learning on top of that it's
okay if you don't get them now
we're all really resilient and we'll be
able to pick up again when this is all
off and we can get back together and do
in-person learning and and focus again
on on all of these things so that's my
first thing is it's okay if you're not
doing everything that you were doing
in the before times um
so it's okay when you set goals
we talked about progress mining to make
sure you're on track but another skill
is actually realizing when this isn't
going to work i can't do this right now
and modifying what your goals are and
thinking about whether maybe it's you're
you're going to extend the time it takes
to meet that goal maybe you're going to
change what the goal is a little bit
that's okay our goals don't are not like
carved in stone we can change them and
it's actually a quite a skill to be able
to recognize when you're off track and
be able to
you know find ways to either get on
track or to modify where what your path
is and where you think you're going to
go
let's say one more thing i also have a
background as a school psychologist and
if you feel like the anxiety that you're
experiencing is
interfering with your your work in your
life and that that worry and the
thoughts you're having are actually
interfering with you know kind of the
the daily things you need to do don't be
afraid to seek help for that either um
if you've got kids you can talk to their
pediatrician you can talk to your
general practitioner for some advice and
and help as well but make sure that
you're staying healthy
yeah i'll just echo that last point
christian made you know sometimes you're
like a frog in boiling water you don't
realize that things are getting bad
until they maybe get too bad and so it's
very you know as soon as you get a sense
it never hurts to go you know talk to
folks get help
etc etc the other thing i would throw
out is
you know sometimes if your goals are too
ambitious they can become debilitating
because they feel daunting or they feel
very hard to start on and i think one
thing that i've heard from christian not
just over the last you know several
minutes but you know in the past is just
you know make some make some of your
goals need to be things that you can get
some wins on uh so that you can kind of
notch them in your belt and and move
move on from that the other thing i'd
recommend is you know and i've talked
about this before is you try out
meditation you know meditation it isn't
some
weird thing all it is is sitting quietly
and becoming observant of your thoughts
and then letting your mind still a
little bit and you'll realize that a lot
of those anxieties a lot of those maybe
even negative feelings they come from a
part of your brain but that isn't your
entire self uh i wouldn't call that a
substitute for getting help if you need
it uh but you know look into it even if
you're able to do two three minutes a
day you know i've talked about before i
used to get anxious on planes uh i still
do a little bit but by meditating it
really helped me actually not only not
get anxious on planes but but in a lot
of other circumstances where i might
have otherwise gotten a little bit
worked up so we have time maybe for for
one more question from facebook rouhoni
arjuni is that saying my child although
very chatty and extroverted at home with
and with the family he's extremely shy
with speaking up on video
with his teacher in class how can i
motivate his participation i've actually
heard this a lot christian ideas
yeah so
there's a couple of things to do so one
is make sure that you know
what is the kind of
importance of speaking out so sometimes
it's not that important if they're not
sharing all the time and they're a
little bit more quiet and that can be
okay but one of the things that speaking
out actually does is it helps us work
through the ideas that we're learning if
you explain them in your own words back
to the teacher or you're answering a
question for the teacher what that's
doing is you're putting into your own
words things you're learning you give
the teacher the opportunity to maybe
correct what's going on there so if you
understand if that's one of the purposes
you want to figure out how to make sure
your child's getting that experience so
it might be actually talking to you a
little bit about what are the things
that they are learning what are the
things how would they have answered that
question that maybe they didn't speak up
to answer so that you can work with them
to do that too
um
second make sure they know
like the protocols what are the norms in
their classroom for speaking up i know
i get on calls where there's 10 people
just 10 people online and it's really
hard to like get in like to
get heard and then it's your turn um and
so
find out what how do they is their
virtual hand-raising function in the
platform you use is there a way that
they can you know how do they indicate
when they do have something to say that
they want to say something and make sure
they know how to do that that's the the
next piece and then finally think about
the in the same way that we talked about
motivating to do
anything how can we
you know think about setting some goals
around how many times hey let's see if
you can speak up you know two times in
this this next hour-long class and
contribute to the discussion and say
where those are so those kind of you
know think about those same principles
if they're not doing it do you want to
bring in some external rewards for them
when they do do that um
and and finally just make sure you've
always got that connection to your
child's teacher so that your child's
teacher's aware that maybe they're
having some of these worries and some of
these concerns about how to speak up as
well so those are those are some
individual thoughts there about you know
how to get kind of kids going in these
zoom calls we've probably all
experienced it ourselves
no absolutely i think i've been on some
of those calls with kristin or have
trouble getting in i hope i hope it
wasn't my fault uh well you know kristin
thank you so much i hope we do this
again as you can see a lot of folks have
a lot of questions about
engagement and motivation so i don't
think this is the end of our
conversation but thanks so much uh for
for joining actually if you have more
questions we're doing a webinar
next week
uh and you can sign up at the the place
you see here so one more plug before we
go uh september 30th for pacific uh
seven eastern
awesome
thanks kristen yeah definitely enjoying
that webinar a lot more good information
like you just got also want to remind
everyone for tomorrow's live stream
national 2020 teacher of the year as i
mentioned uh tabitha rossboy we're going
to be able to talk about uh well she's
she's national teacher of the year but
especially working with younger kids so
i think we'll be able to continue some
of these questions we've been talking
about about motivation especially with
younger kids in distance learning so
look forward to seeing you all tomorrow
have a good day
you